(whooshing)
(upbeat Latin music)
(engine revving)
- All right Believe Nation,
we're in the car with the kids.
There's a street that has
all sorts of Santa Clauses
where everybody bought
the same Santa Claus
from the same store.
So we're going to film it as we drive by.
We have Nina.
We have Hayden.
And we have his two cousins,
Jeffrey and Catherine.
What's up guys?
- Good!
- You want to see some Santa Claus'?
- Yeah!
- Okay, let's go see some Santa Claus'.
There's the first Santa Claus!
- [Hayden] I summon the Santa Claus!
There he is!
- [Evan] Hello Santa!
What's up, mister!
That was a good one.
Apparently one person
bought it one year and then
all the neighbors decided
they would buy it too.
So that's the start.
Let's keep going.
Oh, I see one!
I see one!
- There's Santa!
- Santa Claus, Santa Claus!
There, look at all the Santa's!
(kids laughing)
- [Evan] Ho Santa!
It's a street full of Santa.
- [Kids] Ah ha.
- I see more Santa Claus.
What do you guys want to say?
- [Kids] Ho Ho Ho!
- [Evan] Ho Ho Ho!
Here comes more Santa!
Look at that one!
He's waving from the corner.
I think that last Santa
Claus was my favorite.
What do you think guys?
Oh, I see more!
I see more!
How many have we seen so far?
Like three?
- [Kids] No.
- More than three or less?
More than three?
- Yeah.
- More Santa Claus.
- Maybe there's ten.
- Ten?
- [Jeffrey] Well that's eleven.
- [Evan] 11, I think it's more than that.
Look at all these Santa Claus'.
What do you think Nina?
- Mmm hmm.
- Nina's too busy focusing.
Oh look at the shriveled up Santa!
You going to get the shriveled
up Santa Claus? Look!
- [Nina] I can't see.
- [Evan] Shriveled up Santa.
Ah, he lost his air.
That Santa Claus lost his air.
Very sad.
Let's keep going.
Let's find some more Santas.
Oh look at all the Santas that fell over.
Poor Santa Claus.
All right.
We're almost done!
(ragtime music)
Welcome to Kringlewood.
That sign said "Welcome to Kringlewood".
This street is named Inglewood
and so I guess they called it Kringlewood
after Kris Kringle, Santa Claus.
- [Catherine] Ah, the Santa Claus melt!
- [Evan and Nina] It melted!
- [Evan] Aw, that's the last Santa Claus.
That's it.
All right.
Well thank you guys for
joining us in Kringlewood.
Okay what's your message guys?
What do you want to say?
- Ho Ho Ho Merry Christmas.
- Nice, Merry Christmas.
Thank you guys for watching.
We believe in you!
We hope you continue to...
- [All] Believe!
- In yourself!
And whatever your one word is!
Much love guys!
I got to drive.
We'll see you soon.
Have a great 2017.
(explosion)